bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau 7,8 sport allez c'est parti
comme tous les lundis pour un nouveau
tour de la cus ports du département en
26 minutes
elles viennent d'écrire une page de
l'histoire du tennis de table avec une
victoire lors de la dernière journée de
matchs par équipe
les féminines de l'entente de voisins
saint-arnoult valident leur montée en
nationale une claire fontaine accueillez
ce week-end le women paris soccer show
l'occasion pour de jeunes joueuses
yvelinoise d'obtenir une bourse pour
évoluer au pays roi du football féminin
c'est notre portrait de la semaine il
symbolise l'avenir du volley ball à
montigny à 18 ans bastien lespinasse a
intégré l'équipe première il ya quelques
mois et montre déjà de belles promesses
et évidemment en fin d'émission tous les
résultats du week-end comme d'habitude
mais on passe tout d'abord au tennis de
table
je le disais dans les titres l'entente
de voisins saint-arnoult les féminines
viennent d'écrire une belle une belle
page pardon de l'histoire du tennis de
table yvelinois évidemment pour en
parler l'entraîneur de l'entente
geoffrey nisand bonsoir à vous j'imagine
que vous êtes un entraîneur comblé
depuis quelques jours n'en avec cette
montée en national ça a été difficile de
ton savais pas trop où on était dans
cette phase en nationale 2 on a la
montée à la fin la dernière journée donc
superbe auto des lui je me souviens on
était venu vous voir à l'entraînement
m'aviez dit c'est vrai qu'on a un petit
peu plus le statut de favori que les
saisons précédentes où on a été un peu
la surprise et vous avez assumé ce
statut au final ouais on finit la poule
sans défaite donc sa première fois que
ça nous arrive même de notre montée de
n3 n2 on avait fini avec une défaite
donc là plutôt content on va acheter
d'ailleurs un petit coup d'oeil au
classement si vous voulez bien pour voir
un peu votre domination
elle a été plutôt sans partage sur cette
phase vous avez 20 points à l'issue de
cette journée un petit peu enfin deux
points devant rennes qui a été le seul
vrai concurrent direct 1 sur cette phase
et qui vous a posé problème c'est un peu
d'ailleurs la seule ombre au tableau sur
ses traces puisque c'est le seul match
nul concédé et de surcroît à domicile
donc set partout on peut aussi lui s'il
faut trouver évidemment un petit défaut
dans cette phase
cette première phase de saison dans
ouais on fait cette part tout en menant
6-2 6-2 après l'es12 donc avant les
doubles donc on
on était plutôt bien parti en sachant
que si on avait gagné le match on aurait
validé la montée juste avant juste après
le match de mayenne on a dû attendre le
dernier match donc un peu plus de
pression entre les deux semaines entre
mayenne et coutances justement là cette
dernière journée comment vous l'avez
vécu comment le groupe les filles ont
vécu en sachant qu'il fallait juste un
match nul pour valider la montée c'était
assez dur puisque toute la semaine avant
les signes étaient assez stressé le
samedi matin c'était quelque chose aussi
avec les filles on savait pas quelle
équipe on allait avoir en face de nous
ce que vous pouvez changer un peu leur
équipe et un début de match assez
compliqué qu'est ce qu'on fait on il ya
deux matches par deux matches on va
jusqu'à 3-3 donc on reste collé et à 3 3
on est un peu les choses au clair aux
employés chercher chercher le match nul
en fin de compte on gagne 8,3 dans cette
phase-là sûr c'est sur ces trois
premiers mois de saison ce qui a fait la
différence j'ai l'impression c'est le
manque de blessure vous avez été assez
épargné par rapport à la saison dernière
où justement un ver in fridge 10 20 sont
bas s'était blessé ça avait eu des
conséquences vraiment importantes sur la
fin de saison
mais pas de quoi pas de blessure si
puisqu'on a joué samedi dernier avec
aurore blessée blessée au dos donc à la
fesse et l'a fait les deux matches qu'il
fallait faire qui l a abandonné sur le
dernier match parce que la montée était
assuré que vous avez pu faire un petit
peu la fête on imagine après 7,7 montée
validé nombre exact au wifi exactement
c'est cette montée j'ai l'impression que
c'est aussi l'aboutissement d'un projet
d'ensemble parce que c'est pas juste là
qu'il faut regarder ces deux trois
saisons derrière vous étiez encore en
régionale et puis petit à petit vale est
monté se sont succédé au le projet
initial et je pense l'été arrive à son
terme avec l'objectif final même plus
que l'objectif final on pensait pas
monter en national maintenant on va voir
ce qu'on fait on va on va profiter de
cette phase en nationale 1 puis voir si
on repart sur un autre projet
et sur quel projet objectif final ça
veut dire que vous vous en contenter de
cette montée en national il ya pas de
rêve derrière de pro b qui pourrait être
réalisable avec peut-être un renfort ou
quelque chose comme ça en somme même si
les filles continuent à progresser
je pense qu'on n'a pas encore les
finances au niveau du club pour pouvoir
assumer micro pour l'instant en plus
déjà falloir se maintenir en nationale 1
ça va être un gros morceau puisque les
équipes qui sont nationale 1c il ya un
gros écart en fait entre la nationale 2
et nationale rens donc on va déjà
profiter de cette phase essayer de se
maintenir puis après on verra en fin
d'année ce qu'on propose
mais là vous allez redevenir le petit
poucet dans quelques semaines ça va
peut-être aussi changer la proche des
matches on avait exactement on n'aura
rien à perdre toute façon toutes les
filles seront à quoi seront en forte que
les filles qu'elles vont jouer savoir
que la nationale 1 c'est un peu l'anti
forme de
des pros en fait c'est les équipes deux
des équipes de pro donc à chaque fois on
va avoir une à deux choses de proue en
face c'est tout bénef pour nos filles
elles ont rien à perdre ouais ça sera un
bon apprentissage exact expérience
derrière cette montée là sur ces trois
mois vous le disiez c'est plus le
maintien on va pas chercher plus loin on
va déjà essayer de se battre pour ça
exactement là sont ça va beaucoup
dépendre de la poule qu'on va voir
on le saura c'est bientôt il ya des
équipes qui sont jouables mais qui vont
être à peu près du niveau de rennes
qu'on a je 7,7 cette phase là mais après
il ya des équipes qui sont vraiment
injouable et où on ira plutôt chercher
la perf individuelle que la perf de
l'équipe
très bien merci je ferais d'être passés
sur les 7 8 ans on attend le tirage au
sort des poules de n1 et puis on suivra
évidemment c'est c'est possible en tout
cas maintien on assurer une dès janvier
prochain merci beaucoup merci
clairefontaine accueillez ce week-end le
women paris soccer show l'occasion pour
de jeunes joueuses françaises évinoise
de bon niveau sportif et scolaire
d'obtenir une bourse pour évoluer au
pays roi du football universitaire et
féminin tout en poursuivant leurs études
image de jonathan littman faustine
évolue en division d'honneur régionale
avec montigny le bretonneux
à 18 ans elle rêve du championnat de
soccer américain comme pour la
cinquantaine d'autres joueuses présentes
ce week-end à clairefontaine
cette détection et peut être sa
meilleure chance de venir fouler un jour
ce terrain avec l'équipe de france c'est
une bonne opportunité pour partir à
l'étranger déjà et puis les états unis
c'est un peu le pays du foot féminin
donc voilà c'est toujours bon à prendre
ce genre d'opportunité faut pas là il
faut pas la louper quoi sur la droite du
milieu de terrain camille quelque peu
stressé par la présence des recruteurs a
dû s'adapter aux exercices tactiques à
l'américaine on sait à peu près
similaire après c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment au niveau de l'intensité manger
trop un changement où ils nous en
demande beaucoup plus et enfin faut
vraiment il n'ya pratiquement aucune
pause enfin deux entre les nids les
exercices il demande beaucoup de
physique d'intensité et tout est ce que
en france on a beaucoup moins
apparemment et c'est vrai que c'est
c'est fatigant mais ça va ça ça tient
pour attirer les meilleurs éléments du
week-end la plupart des universités sont
prêtes à prendre en charge la majorité
de leur cursus en moyenne 200 mille
euros sur quatre ans et la vingtaine de
recruteurs présents au bord du terrain
semble avoir repéré quelques talents de
drift et j'ai pu voir des joueuses
techniquement très intéressante et
certaines possèdent également des
qualités athlétiques et un jeu plus
rapide qui leur permettrait d'avoir un
beau parcours dans notre programme
universitaire malgré des actions
intéressantes lors de l'opposition et un
but marqué par faustine les deux jeux
saint-quentinoise n'ont pas obtenu
d'entretiens individuels pour espérer
continuer l'aventuré outre atlantique
allez on enchaîne on passe au
volley-ball la phase aller du
championnat de régionale une vient de se
terminer il ya quelques jours on suit
évidemment comme toutes les saisons
celle de montigny et abdellatif micheli
l'entraîneur emblématique j'ai envie de
dire de l'équipe est parmi nous sur le
territoire bonsoir à vous merci de nous
rejoindre après sept journées 1 vous
pointez donc à la sixième place vous
êtes satisfait en tant qu'entraîneur de
ce premier bilan à mi saison
oui oui oui je suis satisfait parce que
non cette année c'est un peu une année
particulière en termes d'effectifs on a
un effectif très réduit
on démarre la saison avec 10 joueurs là
on en a dans l'optique neuf puisque
un jeune est parti pour des raisons
professionnelles donc on attend au
travail sur le ski prévention de
blessure présence aux entraînements que
ce soit bien régulier qu'on travaille
avec un groupe
réduit mais qui travaillent ensemble le
plus de temps possible donc on semble
bien je dirais pas été bons malgré la 6e
place
vous êtes encore dans le bon wagon en
fait puisque oui à lui vous n'êtes qu'à
en fin de compte deux points de la
troisième place le moniteur s'est
allongée classement donc c'est pas
encore c'est loin d'être perdu même s'il
a que huit équipes engagées
oui voilà il ya huit équipes on est
sixième et à deux points seulement de d2
2e et on a fait quand même des belles
perf contre justement là la deuxième mi
temps les équipes classées 2e au tableau
donc on est capable voilà on y est
capable de 2,2 de repartir lors de la
deuxième phase de 16 ans en en faisant
un travail fin en faisant le nécessaire
avec contre pardon contre les
néo-zélandais ont joué très rapidement
et l'a d'ailleurs on va on va reprendre
après la trêve on essaiera de reprendre
les entraînements assez rapidement pour
justement profiter en fait de 2 à trèves
c'est une période où beaucoup d'équipés
se repose un peu
reprennent un peu tard non on a réussi
de promettre le jour voilà pour entamer
la deuxième phase de championnat contre
les grosses équipes et essayer de jouer
là dessus
les deux derniers matchs on voulait
gagner assez difficilement en trois sets
à deux c'était un petit peu chaotique
entre guillemets à larache comme on dit
serré c'est ça c'est le signe de quoi
d'un manque de mobilisation sur tout le
match de concentration où c'est
l'intensité physique que vous n'arrivez
pas à maintenir sur l'ensemble du match
effectivement il y a dans un premier
temps le l'intensité physique je reviens
sur le nombre réduit de l'effectif donc
il n'y a pas vraiment beaucoup de
possibilités de changement de faire
souffler un peu
les anciens de l'équipe parce que nous
dormons commence un peu sentir enfin
commence un peu à certains classiques
suis donc là dessus on n'a pas vraiment
beaucoup de possibilités donc on essaie
de maintenir avec les moyens qu'on a les
joueurs qu'on a et au bout d'un moment
on sent une certaine un certain
faiblesses surtout physiques et voilà ça
ça traduit un peu les résultats enfin 3
3 2 mai mais on s'en sort on s'en sort
bien voilà c'est un lien ou dernier
match parce qu'on a réussi quand même
mentalement à rester solide soudée
malgré un début de serre un début de
cinquième set on était mené 4 0
donc dans un tie break 5 m enfin voilà
avoir les nerfs solides pour pour
l'angleterre voilà continuer et
l'emporté sur tout donc oui enfin il ya
un petit problème d'effectif doit à
gérer et puis nous enfin voilà enfin le
tie break on ça ne sonne pas plutôt
honneur parce que c'est sur les deux
dernières saisons on a gagné pas mal
l'objectif sur cette deuxième phase
soyons clair ça va être d'aller chercher
un podium l'année dernière vous vous
êtes maintenu mon aussi à peu près dans
les mêmes conditions avec par contre des
clients
cette fois ci ça va être on va essayer
d'éviter ça justement on est en étant
plus constant on nomme un objectif qui
est le lot tableau donc on n'essaie pas
en deux si c'était un objectif qui est
le maintien ou
d'éviter le levain tableau ce que bon
enfin objectif et il faut qu'il soit
enfin l'élément qui est qui qui qui dure
à réaliser
on vise en vise le haut de tableau
pourquoi pas une surprise si on arrive à
jouer comme on veut et réduire un peu le
coin de match si on arrive à donner des
masses points 3e au scratch et facile
voilà sera plus facile cette saison vous
avez intégré un peu de sang neuf
je le disais dans les titres de ce sept
huit sports dans le groupe avec bastien
lespinasse 18 ans qu'on va découvrir un
peu plus longuement tout à l'heure dans
un portrait mais déjà un petit mot sur
ce joueur comment vous l'avais repéré
vous il est venu il est venu en club
comme tous les jeunes pour s'inscrire à
l'époque vous entraîner l'équipe
l'équipe de cadets donc il est venu avec
ses amis il sens crise étaient trois ou
quatre s'inscrire d'un seul coup les
amis je les prie une équipe cadets il a
fait son petit bout de chemin comme tout
le monde deux en cas d une année en
juniors donc en juniors je commençais
déjà pensé à l'intérieur nick et pull
parce qu'il a il avait enfin il est là
il avait du potentiel il avait quelque
chose
bon départ il voit là il avait faim
comme tous les jeunes à son âge il avait
ses priorités les études puis les
parents derrière qui voilà qui pousse
mais sans vraiment voilà donc il y avait
des priorités à respecter quand il a
pris confiance et quand il a assuré ses
études sur tout donc voilà je
j'en ai parlé de ses parents il était
d'accord pour qu'il intègre l'équipe une
et voilà on va lancer là pour l'instant
il est heureux il faut re s est
d'ailleurs mieux
je crois que son intégration se passe
bien quand on était à l'entraînement la
semaine dernière on a recueilli les
impressions de son grand frère en
alliant un petit peu dans l'euro on va
l'écouter d'ailleurs à ce sujet on imite
toujours les gens avec qui on est donc
je commence à un peu à prendre cher sur
ma coupe de cheveux
donc de temps quand il trouve que je
suis un peu trop vrai sur le côté je
trouvais la raison la raison de de le
chambrer c'est un peu le cas à l'heure
actuelle il a l'air vraiment bien
s'intégrer puis surtout de donner le
change aux anciens il je pense qu'il
était déjà intégré le premier le premier
soir il a mis le pied sur le terrain ils
font à l'entraînement il était peinte il
n'était pas impressionné par cette
équipe de seniors les grands enfin les
l'équipe une du club
je pense qu'il avait un côté enfin sûr
de lui et en même temps ingles il écouté
il travaillait bosser il est patient et
je pense que tout de suite avec enfin on
avait un genou 6 qui a joué qui est
l'occasion de jouer avec lui en équipe
d'une heure nicolas philippins non je
pense à l' aider un peu à prendre ses
repères assez rapidement en présence de
jeunes parce que bon
notre politique du club c'est toujours
intérêt déjà assez tôt donc le fait
qu'ils aient des jeunes déjà déjà
intégré ça l'a rassuré et puis tout de
suite il a pris ses repères il a
commencé à jouer le jeu
ces chambres et voilà et vous parlez de
relève c'est intéressant parce que
justement à l'heure actuelle vous
préparez déjà peut-être le plus long
terme on va dire parce que vous avez
pour conclure une petite initiation en
tout cas un début de projet / on va
aller chercher les jeunes là où il veut
les trouver le au plus grand nombre en
tout cas c'est symbolique et que donc on
parlait au départ d'un problème d'un
problème d'effectifs qui est lié en fait
on manque de renouvellement de base
large au niveau haut niveau au niveau
des jeunes donc là cette année on a
senti vraiment qu'il y avait un réel
besoin est urgent une urgence de réagir
et monter un projet en fait de
développement du secteur jeunes donc on
a pris contact avec l'inspection
académique de montigny-le-bretonneux
pour leur proposer un partenariat pardon
pour intervenir dans les écoles
primaires dont le but est de promouvoir
le volet et intervenir dans les écoles
pour leur donner envie de venir voilà de
venir chez nous d'un autre côté il ya
il ya trois partenariats qui vont être
signés là dans les deux semaines avec
trois collèges de montigny saint-exupéry
collège les prêts et collèges la coudre
d'ailleurs je n'en profite pour
remercier madame madame cl ce monsieur
salé et madame hadja connelly qui nous
ont fait confiance ont leur on leur a
proposé le projet cent des gens
passionnés quand on a été les voir et
leur proposer projet ils ont ils ont
tout de suite adhéré
donc le but ce sera de créer une
passerelle entre notre club notre
structure de montigny et les écoles
primaires et les collèges et donc ça
c'est dans un premier temps et donc dans
un deuxième temps c'est on va viser des
écoles qui dont les gamins vont au
collège avec lesquels on a des
partenariats
donc ça nous permettra d'avoir un temps
de pratique et de perfectionnement qui
qui sera assez assez important donc on
va travailler là-dessus on va et si
d'autres écoles sont intéressés on
savoure une calanque par l'oeil ou sur
le site
oui donc voilà d'ailleurs je m'adresse
leurs parents et aux professeurs
d'action voilà c'est si vous avez des
enfants qui sont intéressés ils sont les
bienvenus chez nous on voit là rien
merci beaucoup appellent d'être passés
sur les 7,8 fort et donc on suivra
évidemment l'évolution de ce projet
n'hésitez pas pour voir comment ça
avance du côté des écoles au volley ball
merci beaucoup merci donc on en parlait
tout à l'heure évidemment de ce jeune
bastien lespinasse après cette journée
un live meeting et volley-ball
s'accroche au bon wagon un je disais
pour jouer les premiers rôles en fin de
saison de régionales une pour cela
l'équipe pourra compter sur ce jeune
bastien qui intègre et contre le groupe
il ya quelques mois à peine à seulement
18 ans image de patrick jacques de
dixmude
au départ le volet n'est qu'un simple
loisir un moyen de s'éclater avec ses
copains du lycée
mais après quatre saisons passées à
montigny bastien lespinasse est intégré
dans l'équipe première à tout juste 18
ans de loire le plus jeune du groupe
au début de l'année c'est moi qui ai
fait un peu réticents à aller vers les
autres comme ça et ils m'ont vraiment
vraiment bien aidé c'est vraiment des
gens sympas aimons bien bien pousser
pour m'intégrer dans les filets que
c'était vraiment ils étaient là pour moi
il encourage encore la chute je suis
encore un niveau en dessous par rapport
à eux mais vraiment il n'ya pas de
problème
muette pour ne pas le griller les ailes
l'entraîneur il monte un l'utilisent
avec parcimonie
après cette journée bastien fait moins
de fautes dans le jeu ces attaques sont
plus tranchantes
ambitieux il veut continuer à grappiller
du temps de jeu pour aider l'équipe
ils ont veulent envie d'aller loin il ne
montre pas mais au fond de lui même il
fait qu'il voit là qu'il a cet état de
performances de développement et de
performances l envie de performer
c'est pour ça que pour l'instant lilith
dont il bosse et je sens que même lycée
quinze jours voire vous il va percer
j'ai vraiment l'impression d'avoir une
encore une étape de passée mais la plus
grosse que j'ai jamais eue depuis je me
suis inscrit dans ce club ses
c'est vraiment la grande marche les gars
de l'équipe me l'ont dit ils ont dit que
j'avais vraiment au cours de l'année
n'ont vu progresser j'avais vraiment
franchi une étape et il est bien aidé
par les anciens qui l'ont évidemment
plier au traditionnel bizutage est sûre
non c'est un peu pour créer un
l'entente un peu psychologique et le
fait que le jour où ils rentrent sur le
terrain qui nous apporte qu'ils soient à
l'aise déjà et le fait d'être à l'aise
c'est un plus dans le soutien dans le
groupe pour arriver à gagner des matches
à croire que l'américain attire le
succès cette saison bastien joué quatre
matches tous remportés par montigny
on passe tout d'abord au football dans
ces résultats 10e journée de promotion
d'honneur guyancourt s'est imposé à
domicile 2 à 0 face à l'uja maccabi
paris le sg remonte à la 9e place de son
côté dans la poule b deux de chute pour
trappe les trappistes ont sombré chez le
troisième parisy 4 buts à 1 avec cette
seconde défaite consécutive les saint
quentinois dégringole au classement de
leur poule ils sont désormais septièmes
à neuf points du leader nanterre à noter
un camp division d'honneur la rencontre
opposant versailles à bobigny a été
reportée en rugby 11e journée de
fédérale 3 plaisir a infligé le carton
du week-end à sucy score final 41 10
avec six essais inscrits le bonus
offensif les plaisirs roi confortent
leur deuxième place au classement
derrière orléans handball féminin
évidemment avec montini 10e journée de
nationale 2 est troisième victoire
consécutive pour les signé monteyne
elles se sont imposées cette fois ci à
beauvais d'un petit but 25-24 et pointe
à la 6e place au classement
en basket national une femme on suit
évidemment le l'entente le
chesnay-versailles 12e journée ils l ont
mené un jusqu à deux minutes du buzzer
mais finalement être sont inclinés 2 5
points à rezé 65 à 60 des filles de
stéphane rôle et restent englués à la
10e place chez les hommes
bilan mitigé ce week-end trappe 8e s'est
incliné à gravenchon 69 à 56 et le rcv a
retrouvé la victoire à domicile face au
dernier oissel 67 à 59 encore quelques
infos avant de nous quitter tout d'abord
du baby basket ce week-end se déroulait
le traditionnel plateau de baby basket
au gymnase des droits de l'homme de
guyancourt plus de 140 enfants issus de
quatorze clubs du département
répartis sur huit ateliers dans le baby
on aborde tout d'abord la discipline
sous une forme ludique sous forme
d'ateliers ach dans la difficulté de
maîtriser son corps au milieu des
joueurs tout en gardant le contrôle du
ballon c'est vraiment de l'initiation
donc après on va les conduire petit à
petit a progressé à la fois
techniquement et d'apprendre à jouer à
collecter l'équipement également
concassé âge là ils jouent souvent un
petit peu individuellement
petit à petit on province à les faire se
placer sur le terrain et à leur
apprendre à se placer les hommes par
rapport aux autres par rapport à ses
adversaires en escrime ensuite toujours
là l'escrimeuse de trappes germinal
pachanga après ces bons résultats la
saison dernière et bien il ya quelques
jours elle a pris la troisième place de
la coupe du monde au luxembourg un bon
résultat cumulé à la saison passée qui
lui permet d'obtenir le troisième rang
mondial chez les juniors dernière 2
derrière deux italiennes
camilla mancini francesca palumbo du
vélodrome pour finir évidemment cyclisme
en attendant l'ouverture des portes du
vélodrome le 13 janvier prochain
nous vous ferons découvrir en
exclusivité au cours d'une émission
spéciale ce jeudi dans le 7-8 actu et
aux côtés de wilfrid richy les taureaux
poutou premier tour de piste par dont
des membres de l'équipe de france sur le
vélodrome est la reine de bmx
quelques dates pour l'agenda du week-end
évidemment pour finir cette émission de
la boxe éducative tout d'abord tout le
week-end championnat des yvelines
catégories benjamins minimes et cadets
rendez vous au gymnase du bois de
l'étang pour assister aux assauts du
futsal championnat des divines également
pour les u15 et les u17 rendez-vous tout
le week-end au palais des sports d'el en
cours c'est la fin de ce set 8 sport
merci beaucoup de l'avoir suivi bonne
soirée à lundi prochain